the kids are going to want snacks don't
feed them Kitty that's how it started
the first time I'm going to get Fritos
Tostitos Doritos all the guidos I am
back baby I love that so many members of
the original cast are back I mean who
knew that Jackie and Kelso would get
married in real life could you be any
more annoying
yes
well I think they're just like
two amazing humans number one yeah and
then for them to come together to create
two more amazing humans is just gold I
mean it's just it's a gift of the Gods I
also couldn't stop laughing during the
entire episode with Fez
welcome back to chances
it's always an honor to have your hair
in my chair so it's Shay fast but Wilmer
goes yeah Chez Fez well we died we died
because that's such a perfect Fez thing
that was such a happy moment for us
because that just reminded us that took
us way back to seven each show you know
that's something Wilmer would do
you don't have bad luck
the reason that bad things happen to you
is because you're a dumbass
do you have to practice saying the word
dumbass to get back into character red I
get plenty of practice because for some
reason
young guys
come up to me and ask me to call them a
dumbass I don't know I guess they give
feel like they have a little piece of
the show then they're they're a little
tiny part of the show if I do that so
so I'm happy to oblige so tell her what
you say I say anyone who wants to be
called a dumbass is a Dumbass Dumbass